bonjour naim chili merci d'être en
direct avec nous est ce que vous êtes
surpris par ce constat que dresse l'unef
dans son dernier rapport
non pas du tout c'est un constat avec
qui elle s'est cognée depuis un moment
il fit tout révéler initiation que
lanson dissuasion te connaissait elle
dans ce pays c'est à dire que sous le
quinquennat des mails macron la
précarité étudiante a largement augmenté
pour deux raisons principales à la fois
les dirigeants qui a pu mettre en place
comme la double baisse des appels ou
encore plus tôt les noms mesure le fait
que malgré plusieurs mois de crise
sanitaire plusieurs confinement il a
fallu attendre une vague de suscite
étudiants pour que le gouvernement
commencent à réaliser qu'ils avaient un
problème avec les siens dans ce pays et
mettre en place certaines mesures comme
la généralisation des repas un euro mais
il faut savoir que la grande majorité de
ces quelques mesures correctives mises
en place à l'époque elles ont été faits
à base de taxes étudiante et non pas
d'investissements propres de l'état ce
qui montre bien le refus du gouvernement
d'investir dans sa jeunesse selon vous
quelles sont les décisions qui ont le
plus aggravé les la situation des
étudiants
bas ce que je disais donc à la fois par
exemple les double baisse des appels à
la fois la baisse de 5 euros tout début
du quinquennat et puis la récente
réforme du king mode de calcul ce qui
fait que tout un tas d'étudiants soit
non plus des deux logements sont vus ces
êtres grandement baissé à d'autres rues
d'autres mesures structurelles par
exemple le lit sur un étranger quand on
augmente les frais dans les esprits des
inscriptions à 2700 euros laissant sous
3700 euros en master 2 vous faites ça
fait augmenter la précarité et une
pétillante d'autant plus ces étudiants
n'ont pas accès à un système de bourse
et puis au delà de ça et aussi ce que je
faisais les noms mesure là où nicolas
sarkozy françois hollande qui déjà avait
pas beaucoup agi pour la jeunesse eh
bien ces deux présents soit ils allaient
augmenter le montant des bourses soit le
nombre de bénéficiaires soit leur durée
est bien emmanuel la con c'est le seul
président n'avoir pris aucune de ces
mesures durant son quinquennat
concrètement quelles sont les
difficultés quotidiennes que rencontrent
ces étudiants en grande précarité
ils sont à ses multiples ça va être par
exemple se soigner tout un tas
d'étudiants boursiers ou non denses et
qui refusent de soigner par faute de
moyens ça va être aussi se nourrir en
l'absence de tête à ces images de
distribution alimentaire et il faut
l'avoir en tête à la précarité étudiante
elle est structurelle elle était déjà
présente avant de co lead quant à lyon
il ya un étudiant qui s'immolent par le
feu devant le creusot lyon pour dénoncer
cette situation c'était avant la crise
sanitaire et donc si on veut arrêter de
voir chaque jour chaque semaine des
centaines d'étudiants qui font des
heures de queue pour avoir des paquets
de pâtes plutôt que réaliser leur court
derrière le bureau eh ben il faut mettre
en place des réponses structurelles faut
réformer scène de bourse et si on le
voilà maintenant donner une chance à
charge nette pour réussir ensuite ses
études et obtenir des diplômes il faut
mettre en place le type de mesures aussi
non ces images elles pourront continuer
f sont va pas de s'arrêter ce sont des
mesures qui sont indispensables pour
pour remédier à la paupérisation des
étudiants
je pense à la fois des mesures très
court terme à la fois par exemple
gouvernement vient d'annoncer que les
repeints euros au crous sont dans un
huis clos aux étudiants boursiers faut
savoir qu'il trois quarts des studios
ont pas accès aux bourses dont deux de
fait c'est largement impacter la
population de gens pensent que déjà
c'est la vigueur et devrait être un
rester pour l'ensemble des étudiants
pareil augmenter les bourses de 100
euros pendant 110 kg ans et zahia des
mesures de court terme qui pourrait on
peut améliorer la situation faut pas
oublier que la seule l'aide de mâcon
pendant la crise sanitaire ses 150 euros
versée une fois et a seulement un quart
des étudiants les experts boursiers donc
elle déjà il y aura des mesures à mettre
en place et puis de manière plus globale
mouscron revendique c'est une réforme
totale système de bourse aujourd'hui on
a bien conscience avec ses très sincères
qui répondent pas à la situation
actuelle et qu'il vient pas en aide
véritablement aux étudiants et aux
étudiantes et aux réformes des systèmes
de bourses pour permettre à lens en
question de sortir du seuil de pauvreté
c'est une réforme qui est indispensable
un élément qui a aussi aggravé la
situation des étudiants c'est avec le
confinement plus d'un tiers d'entre eux
ont dû renoncer à leur job étudiant
selon l'observatoire de la vie étudiante
est ce que vous pensez que les choses
vont aller en s'améliorant puisque la
situation sanitaire est censé
s'améliorer
calais s'améliorera d'ici quelques temps
en tout cas une chose qui est sûre c'est
qu'il ya beaucoup d'étudiants qui ont
décroché pendant cette période on a vu
les résultats les étudiants
boursiers par rapport aux étudiants non
boursiers on voit regard différentiel en
fonction du soutien qu'ils reçoivent des
aides financières ou pas dans la
capacité à réussir malgré la crise
sanitaire donc quand même situation elle
s'améliore dans quelques temps le
faisait il ya déjà aujourd'hui des
étudiants qui sont les chèques gens qui
meurent veux te faire un peu
grandiloquent mais c'est la réalité
quand on peut pas se nourrir et ben oui
aux morts à la fin il ya toujours eu une
vague de suicides qui s'est pas terminée
actuellement au sein à 18 ans de ce pays
donc même si on en parle moins d'après
bulle médiatique c'est sûr elle s'est
pas arrêté et c'est pour ça que l'on dit
attention peut-être que le gouvernement
parle un peu moins et que du coup à la
focale s'est déplacé mais pourtant tout
un tas de problématiques qu'on parlait
en janvier est toujours présente et donc
c'est pour ça qu'il est vraiment urgent
urgent d'agir les discours sont
alimentaires on n'en parle pas mais
elles sont toujours présentes malgré
l'été malgré le fait qu'un certain
d'étudiants travaillent encore
aujourd'hui puisque même quand on
travaille souvent cédé jobs qui sont eux
rémunéré souvent c'est que pendant une
petite partie de l'année et puis aussi
qu'on travaille ben ça augmente les
risques d'échec à l'inversé puisque on
est moins concentré sur nos études et
donc moins qu'à placer pouvoir réussir
est ce que vous sentez parmi les
étudiants à un sentiment d'abandon du
gouvernement
par un sentiment d'abandon totalement
quand on voit le nombre de mois qu'il a
fallu pour que la misère sinon supérieur
préoccupe vraiment de notre situation à
celle ci un sentiment il est totalement
injustifiée mais aussi un grand
ressentiment
une sensation d'être désabusé c'est à
dire que voilà on a eu beaucoup de
communication on écoute le gouvernement
l'impression qu'ils ont tout fait il ya
un temps un jeu à une solution que toi
été prise en compte pourtant quand on
regarde la réalité concrète il n'y a
rien qui est derrière est au contraire
comment la cité avec la base d'appels
c'est l'initiation qui s'est aggravée
donc un sentiment d'abandon mais aussi
une envie de crier sa révolte sa colère
de dire voilà la situation c'est pas
faute à pas de chance le gouvernement
est clairement responsable de
l'aggravation de la situation au niveau
d'un suivi au jour dans ce pays merci
beaucoup on a aimé chili est d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes secrétaire national
d'alternative étudiante merci